[Musique]
à quelques jours de la rentrée scolaire
le département souhaite apporter son
aide aux enfants scolarisés relevant de
l'aide sociale à l'enfance
la collectivité leur offre un kit
scolaire composé de cahiers de rames de
papier ou encore de stylo mais également
d'une aide allant de 50 à 250 euros pour
l'achat de leurs fournitures scolaires
selon l'âge et le statut de l'enfant
chaque enfant qu'il né sur le territoire
de la région doit avoir les mêmes
chances que tout autre enfant qu'il né
sur le territoire de la république et
lorsque vous avez des difficultés
notamment parce que la vie est chère et
bien le département doit accompagner les
enfants bien sûr mais aussi les parents
et je tiens à dire aussi ce que nous
avons construit un partenariat avec les
commerces de la région qui vendent des
produits scolaires de façon à ce que les
familles qui relèvent de l'aide sociale
à l'enfance us bénéficier de réductions
soient ces mêmes fournitures une mesure
qui permettra aux assistants familiaux
d'accompagner au mieux la jeunesse
réunionnaise
avec les difficultés financières pour
mon compte
toutes les familles réunionnaises
il est nécessaire pour nous en tant
qu'assistant de familiales et les
budgets que nous avons d'aider ces
enfants dans l'épanouissement en fait de
leur apprentissage scolaire c'est un
beau coup de pouce parce que pour
mousser c'est pas facile parce que le
jeune que celle à au monde 2010 quelque
chose là pour la rentrée parce qu'il va
rentrer au lycée donc c'est un vrai coup
de pouce produit parce que
pour l'aider tout au long de cette année
elle c'est bien parce que au moins à des
effets scolaires pour la rentrée et
c'est bien on va pas se plaindre parce
qu'on n'a pas eu tâche aux tâches c'est
déjà bien d'avoir ça du coup bas pour la
rentrée mais on va faire avec ce qu'il
faut de notre côté pour bien avoir nos
diplômes et cetera
notre avenir le département a l'ambition
d'aller encore plus loin dans son
accompagnement aux jeunes de l'aide
sociale à l'enfance nous aimerions aussi
au delà de l'achat de fournitures
scolaires les aider aussi dans le suivi
de ces enfants
sur l'éducatif de ses enfants
particulièrement dans dans le suivi des
rendez-vous orthophonie coude au niveau
thérapeutique en général pour que ses
enfants seraient prioritaires dans les
listes d'attenté sont longues ici le mot
sur le territoire
afin de soutenir au mieux des assistants
familiaux le département va augmenter
leur dotation mensuelle à 153 euros par
mois et par enfant
[Musique]
non